finally tonight this week's notable
quotables we're not changing any stars
that money was not campaign money from
another award for him and the president
repaid it oh I didn't know that he did
go get his facts straight we give the
very best information that we have at
the time and to be bringing up that kind
of crap and if we bring it up witch
hunts all the time that's all you want
to talk about the Department of Justice
is not going to be extorted people are
not going to Caravan or otherwise
Stampede our border Iran large I've been
100% right
outlaw Pruitt he's floating the Clean
Air Act at slavery for 400 years that's
not like a choice did your mom ever tell
you that we should wash her mouth that
would so put those lives one of the
first rules is don't talk down to people
right so so I'll speak to you all right
up here like to begin with a question
that's on everybody's mind
how do you pronounce your
whereas mark mark mark mark was John you
know the sweetest words the president I
ever hear are the words I'm praying for
you and we hear it a lot we have with us
nice lady Michelle wolf and yeah sure
you can groan all you want should've
done more research before you got me to
do this
well there you go and that wraps up
another week we made it through which
means only two more working days until
Monday